news contributor Ted Williams uh Ted we
see the with surveillance footage of the
shooter uh he's obviously at large he's
obviously dangerous he's obviously
killed a number of people from a law
enforcement standpoint how do you go
about you know creating the the best
case scenario which is getting him as
quickly as possible uh before he finds
other
people well Sean what you have now is
all hands on deck there in that Leon
main area they have the video of this
one person that you're talking about
here they see that person is being a
white male with a long rifle or this
suspect uh the big question that is not
answered is uh how many other
individuals are actually involved is it
just one single individual so what
they're doing is they're trying to find
and make that determination and one of
the things that they using as any video
feeds that's in that area they're also
talking to as many
witnesses can but what they're dealing
with here is clearly from what all
indications are T if I may interrupt you
for a second in that area
unfortunately uh Fox News has confirmed
now the number has gone quite higher it
is now 22 confirmed debt as we speak I
know uh keep uh I didn't want to
interrupt you but that just came across
uh our our newswire uh continue with
what we were saying by the way we now
have reportable let me give you one
other thing if I may if I can reportable
per law enforcement preliminary
information is 22 dead three locations
Walmart uh Distribution Center a bar and
a third location FBI supporting
mobilized main State Police are taking
the lead investigative role possible
suspect is now in custody so we do have
some news on that front breaking as we
speak as well go ahead Ted pick it up
from there well one of the things again
that they're trying to determine even if
they've got a suspect in question is are
are there other individuals out there
that are also actively involved as you
know they've asked everyone in that
vicinity to shelter in place meaning to
lock your doors stay inside let law
enforcement do its job uh so that's one
of the things that's going on I hope
Sean that you're absolutely right that
there is somebody in custody because
that clearly will tell law enforcement
as to whether they're looking at just
one single individual or if there are
other individuals that they should be on
the lookout for or doing this
unfortunate uh uh incident here uh in
Maine yeah it really is unfortunate
we're following the story stay right
there Ted Williams we get hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else